Do you remember Cat Clicker?
Do you remember the pain on Andy's face as the project
requirements changed again, and again, and again?
I remember it very well.
Poor Andy.
Well, a, anyway.
Our final version has two main areas.
It's going to have a list of cats, and
a cat detail area, where you can click on the currently selected cat.
Well as it turns out, the last few lessons have gotten us ready to
build Cat Clicker, and this time we'll build it right.
Now, I'll tell you from personal experience.
Even though, I've built a lot of applications and structures with wood, too, for
that matter, one thing I hate doing, is planning.
But every time I don't plan things out, they end up taking much more time.
And by the end, I wish I'd spent the extra time to plan.
So, let's take some time and plan this out.